remember my dad picking me up from
school one day and he just woke up
having worked all night you know and he
was like I don't know what's going on
with you but this whole fake and sick
thing is is over we got to figure this
out and I just started crying and I was
like I just never see you anymore man
and whenever I you always pick me up and
then he was quiet the whole ride home
not even any music on my dad's a big
music guy I remember him not having any
music on and me just sitting next to him
is he like gently sobbed and that was
one of two times I saw my dad cry one
being when his mom passed away which was
first my grandmother passed away after
this after yeah yeah so this is the
first time you saw your dad ever cry
yeah and it was that like man crying
where it looks like you know you're
trying to fight off an aneurysm so
like you're just gonna like beat a heart
attack you know yeah through
perseverance
yeah
I got this yeah I'll be fine yeah you
know how to take the wheel
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler